et ça doit être dur de passer un hiver
seul c'est
de loin c'est triste quand même
oui il y a des jours où je m'ennuie pas
mais d'autres
où je m'ennuie beaucoup
[Musique]
comment s'appelle ce hameau et ça peut
être
combien y a-t-il de maison et bien ça
fait 6 6 maison et combien sont habitées
rien qu'une il y a que la mienne la
vôtre seulement la mienne seulement
tout le monde est parti
et il y a quelques années il y avait
d'autres habitants ah oui même il y a
deux ans il y avait un monsieur qui
habitait à côté
un homme âgé de 70 ans
est-ce que vous voudriez nous montrer
votre amour
ça doit vous paraître long les soirées
d'hiver
comment les occupez-vous et bien je vais
un peu jusqu'à 9 heures
et puis je vais me coucher j'écoute la
radio pendant ce temps et après je
vais me coucher et je dors pas toute la
nuit
comment faites-vous pour faire vos
courses pour votre avitaillement et bien
c'est à dire qu'il passe
il passe des épiciers ils passent le
boucher passe le boulanger
alors ils amènent leur ravitaillement et
le facteur vient jusqu'ici vient tant
qu'il y a pas trop de neige mais dès
qu'il y a un peu de neige les chemins
sont pas
commodes alors il peut pas venir il
faudrait faire la trace et il y a pas
assez de monde et vous vous quittez
quelquefois le village
quelquefois quand il fait pas trop
mauvais quand il y a pas de neige
mais comme à ce moment je peux sortir
malgré qu'il y a un peu de neige je sors
quand même je suis assez courageuse
et le village la maison la plus proche
est loin
le village le plus proche c'est compris
[Musique]
à travers les arbres à travers oui à
travers des arbres quand vous avez
beaucoup d'arbres tout autour du village
c'était des chambres je l'ai vu en ce
moment c'est j'ai vu des pommes de terre
j'ai vu du seigle
et maintenant ce sont de grands arbres
bons à couper des gens alors voyez s'il
y a longtemps
je suis pas jeune et mon âge devient
être inscrit sur ma personne
j'ai 84 ans et ben enfin je vais assez
bien je me porte assez bien je suis
agile je peux marcher je vais où je veux
et non plus je suis pas sourde j'ai
toutes mes facultés
ça doit être difficile ça doit être dur
de passer un hiver seul c'est essayer
éloigné c'est c'est triste quand même
oui il y a des jours où je m'ennuie pas
mais d'autres jours où je m'ennuie
beaucoup mon jardin me distrait beaucoup
je le fais baisser et puis moi je lance
je travaille pendant l'été ça me fait
une distraction
et vous aimez les fleurs et oui j'aime
bien les fleurs
seulement c'est
ça coûte cher aussi
et puis je suis tellement seule que
j'ai pas du goût comme si il y avait
quelqu'un de plus
ça fait longtemps que vous faites de la
dentelle
et bien il y a pas très longtemps depuis
depuis la mort de ma sœur
avant je travaillais à ma couture et
j'ai fait un petit peu de dentelle pour
me distraire
c'est un apport intéressant
c'est bien ce qu'il y a de moins
d'intéressant c'est pas assez payé le
bénéfice est sans doute tout pour les
pour les marchands
ici il y a les champignons aussi les
gens s'intéressent beaucoup aux
champignons mais moi maintenant je suis
un peu trop fatigué pour y aller quand
même
vous les connaissez bien moi je les
connais
j'en ai bien
cueillir assez souvent
et maintenant si j'en trouve
quelques-uns sur mon passage je les
ramasse aussi
ça gagne mieux que la dentelle
vous n'avez pas de bête ou de poule
c'est pas trop de travail ça
me fait une distraction et puis des œufs
j'ai pas besoin d'en acheter et le
maintiennent
vous avez des chats
oui j'ai deux chats
que il me fait bien peine de me séparer
d'eux quand je partirai parce que je
comptais aller habiter en ville je
voudrais pas finir ma vie toute seule
ici
tant que ma santé est bonne je m'ennuie
bien un peu ici mes enfants tant pis
[Musique]